lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar sobre las cuentas de ahorro para
el retiro llamadas 401k que quizás
ustedes ya hayan escuchado hablar de
ellas y para que se vayan dando una idea
de lo que trata esto estas cuentas de
ahorro para el retiro son bastante
parecidas a las cuentas de ahorros
tradicionales así pues son muy
similares
a las cuentas de ahorro para el retiro
tradicionales
en que se parecen bueno se parecen en
que los impuestos son diferidos
es decir se ingresa dinero
ingresa
y dinero
antes de impuestos
tanto en la cea de 401 como en las
tradicionales el dinero puede crecer o
invertirse dentro de la misma cuenta así
pues el dinero
crece
dentro de la cuenta
y no se cobran impuestos
sin impuestos
y se puede retirar el dinero se puede
retirar el dinero
después
de cumplir
59 y medio años
que es esencialmente la edad en la que
uno se comienza a retirar y que por lo
tanto va a necesitar el dinero del
ahorro para el retiro y cuando se hace
el retiro después de esta edad entonces
entonces se pagan impuestos
entonces se pagan los impuestos
del dinero
y esto es a lo que se refieren las
personas con impuestos diferidos no se
paga el dinero al inicio pero si se paga
cuando se retira y para muchas personas
esto es útil ya que cuando están
ingresando el dinero muy probablemente
están en un tabulador de impuestos que
es elevado ya que están recibiendo
bastantes ingresos y al diferir los
impuestos cuando los sacan a esta edad
lo más probable es que ya lo estén
ganando tanto dinero porque de hecho se
están retirando y el tabulador de
impuestos en el que están sea bastante
más bajo que cuando ingresaron el dinero
así que el impuesto que se paga en este
punto va a ser menor y en general si uno
tiene que pagar 50 centavos en el futuro
o 50 centavos hoy puede ser mejor
pagarlos en el futuro ya que esos 50
centavos en el futuro valdrán menos de
lo que valen en la actualidad así que
ese es un buen motivo para diferir el
pago de impuestos sin embargo en el pago
de impuestos no vamos a pagar impuestos
solo del dinero que ingresamos se van a
pagar impuestos de todo el
he ingresado más las ganancias que tuvo
durante el tiempo que se encontró en
esta cuenta así que se van a pagar
impuestos de más cantidad así que se
paga impuestos de ingresos del total de
la cuenta o del total que se retira de
todo el dinero que se retira se tienen
que pagar impuestos y en ambos casos va
a haber una penalización
una penalización
si no se comienza a retirar el dinero si
no se retira al menos una parte del
dinero de esta cuenta a los 70 años y
medio y eso es si no se retira dinero
aunque hay ciertos requerimientos
especiales dependiendo en donde se esté
trabajando y también va a haber
penalizaciones si se hace un retiro
antes de los 59 y medio años y esto
aplica tanto para la cr 401 acá como
para las tradicionales así que cuando
queremos retirar antes de los 59 años y
medio primero vamos a tener que pagar
impuestos pagar impuestos de los
retirados impuestos
y lo retirado
y además se tendrá que pagar una
penalización penalización del 10 por
ciento de todo lo que retiramos antes de
esta edad
así que por esta razón ustedes tienen
que estar seguros de que no van a
necesitar o que no van a sacar ese
dinero que inviertan en esta cuenta
antes de esta edad todas estas
características son compartidas o son
iguales en estos tipos de cuenta cuál es
la diferencia por qué razón existe estas
cuentas de ahorro 401k ya que a más pues
son una buena opción para diferir
impuestos para tener un ahorro para el
retiro y que además ese ahorro pueda
invertirse y crecer y ambos pues me
obligan a asegurarme que no voy a tocar
ese dinero hasta que tenga la edad para
retirarme bueno ya vimos todo esto son
las cosas que tienen en común ahora
veamos las diferencias entre estas
cuentas las diferencias las vamos a
escribir aquí abajo la primera es que
las cuentas 401k tienen un límite
superior mayor un límite mayor
y si vemos los datos del 2010 aunque
esta información cambia continuamente en
el año del 2010 el límite de estas
cuentas fue de 16.500 dólares esto es lo
que uno puede ingresar en estas cuentas
esta es de las cuentas 401 cam mientras
que para la cuenta tradicional tenemos
que es de cinco mil dólares en el modo
tradicional y de hecho un acabo de
acordar de otra cosa que tienen en común
lo voy a anotar aquí es que uno puede
acelerar el crecimiento de estas cuentas
agregando más dinero después de cumplir
los 50 años y esto es algo que tenemos
en común en estas dos cuentas es decir
puedo poner más dinero después de los 50
años que lo especificado en estos
límites de acá sin embargo en esta
modalidad 401k se puede agregar todavía
más
porque tiene un límite mayor con
respecto a la tradicional tanto antes de
los 50 años como después de los 50 años
otra diferencia es que las cuentas 401k
tienden a ser organizadas por los
empleadores
organizadas por empleadores
y desde tu punto de vista esto tiene dos
características primero el empleador va
a especificar las posibles inversiones
específicas posibles inversiones
así que esencialmente estos empleadores
administran este tipo de cuentas en
lugar de sus empleados así que estas
cuentas son administradas por la
compañía y esta compañía decide cuáles
son las posibles inversiones en dónde va
a ir este dinero y otra cosa ya que esto
es administrado por los empleadores es
que el empleador
aporta la misma cantidad que da del
empleado la misma cantidad a esta cuenta
o podría podría aportar la misma
cantidad es decir si el empleado aporta
esta cantidad para su cuenta su
empleador podría aportar también esta
cantidad para la cuenta del empleado así
que esto es algo que podría inspirar al
empleado a tener este tipo de cuenta
sobre todo si se tiene un empleador que
es bastante generoso y otra diferencia
aunque ésta podría verse un poquito
superficial ya que depende de lo que uno
quiera ver es que el dinero se saca
directamente del pago el empleado nunca
ve ese dinero el dinero se obtiene
directamente del sueldo del empleado el
empleado nunca ve este dinero se lo
descuentan antes de pagarse aquí lo
pongo antes de pagarle
y así que era más claro en el cr
tradicional uno como empleado todo ese
dinero de su pago y lo invierte en la
cuenta y cuando se reportan los
impuestos esto en la cuenta tradicional
se reporta como una deducción por lo que
no se tiene que pagar impuestos de esa
cantidad aunque funcionalmente estas dos
cosas son iguales ese aspecto en ambas
cuentas es igual si queremos ver las
ventajas y desventajas de cada una de
estas cuentas si estamos en la 401 k es
decir tenemos la opción de entrar en una
cuenta de este tipo pues realmente es
una opción bastante buena ya que
tendremos un límite mayor de la cantidad
de dinero que podemos ingresar en ella y
además el empleador podría aportar la
misma cantidad de la que uno invierte y
otra cosa que es positiva es que existe
la opción de tomar prestado dinero de
esta cuenta de la 401 k
tomar prestado
dinero de ella
sin penalización
aunque se tiene que devolver el dinero y
pagar intereses de lo prestado a esta
cuenta aunque esto no se puede hacer con
una cr tradicional y bueno viendo esto
ustedes podrían decirme bueno pues cómo
es que alguien está interesado en usar
una sede tradicional si existe esto
bueno primero ustedes pueden tener ambas
cuentas en la acr tradicional ustedes
tienen mucho más control y flexibilidad
sobre dónde quieren que se invierta su
dinero a lo mejor en este caso de la
401k sus empleadores les dicen que la
única opción de inversión es en la misma
compañía y enlace aérea tradicionales
ustedes pueden invertir en lo que gusten
y espero que con esto se hayan aclarado
las diferencias y las características de
este tipo de cuentas